let's talk about coronavirus you know
the cases you're in india
we hear about the news it's uh
the seven day average uh in february in
cases was eleven thousand one forty five
a day
the seven day average right now as of
may 9th is 389
000 cases a day the seven day average on
death is nearly four thousand thirty
nine forty one right and
we're seeing the story i'm mentoring uh
helping out with this one
uh company in india i sit on their board
and i'm talking to them and i said what
does it look like he says you don't even
know how bad it is right now they're in
the
capital where most of the covet is
taking place workers going home
nobody's buying p no there's a lot of
fear there right okay
so then a number comes out saying well
modi wasn't responsible he said he's
gonna get more vaccines out he didn't
doesn't this validate because the number
that came out
is china india needs 1.2 million doses
of vaccine shots right 1.2 billion
that's a big number 1.2 billion and
there's only one place you can go to
to get 1.2 billion and you know who that
is i mean
that's what a lot of people are talking
about it's china
doesn't that kind of validate the power
of
power china has over the world or you
disagree with that
i disagree because we are the largest
producer of vaccines
not china so if you don't
became complacent because uh by
by end of december and january
of uh this year 2021 it looked as if the
corona was gone
and the prime minister went and boasted
that i have solved the problem corona
i've defeated them
in the world economic survey i have one
economic conference or whatever it's
called in switzerland
and he of course it was online but he
uh his speech he said i've solved this
problem i'm ready to assist any other
country which also
solves the problem and out of the blue
this second
wave came and we we had forgotten to see
the the there is a lot of he said
we are a democracy so we got a lot of
lobbies
and uh the british uh uh
oxford uh uh zenika or whatever it's
called
they wanted it to be manufactured in
india
there was an indian company
which was doing by by a different route
they were producing these machines which
are far safer
tested and effective too and i took that
there but originally when the prime
minister announced that the contract is
going
he only announced this astrozenica
vaccine produced in in pune and now the
owner has gone off to london and he's
sitting there
because there have been so many i mean
there must have been 200 deaths in that
whereas in this
other one co-vaccine uh
produced entirely domestically uh
there's been rdne
so we we became complacent and we are
paying the price for that complacency
and this attempt to want to grab credit
and then
project yourself in the world this
weakness of politicians you know this is
partly responsible
because nobody wanted to as i would
utter a word of caution say i was first
i was in i'm the parliamentary committee
on health
so i was the one who fought and got the
the co-vaccine
to be cleared on the same day and now
the government is putting all his faith
in this
vaccine because the other one is you
know we don't know where it is
when the owner himself has gone away to
britain
we don't know what's going to happen so
we yes we are behind we are
responsible for what happened in a
matter like uh oxygen i'm
surprised a country like india not being
able to supply oxygen
because we didn't make make arrangements
because oxygen requires a lot of
you know trucking and transportation and
cylinders
and so on and none of that was being
thought of just
having enough oxygen is not enough so so
in in what so you're saying as far as
the vaccine goes india doesn't at all
rely on china for any of the vaccine
because you can produce you're the
largest manufacturer
what what does india rely on china with
because
if there's one thing india did in the
last 12 months you guys
banned tick tock all these apps i think
on one week it was a hundred
apps that were fully banned of china and
india which i applaud
for them to take that position because
nobody else is willing to take that
position
a lot of people are scared trump almost
did something where he forced them to
want to
sell tic tac but you know it was kind of
confusing how that ended up taking place
what what does
india rely on china with and
if it's nothing what how does
how does india view china does india
view china as an ally or there's a view
as they
you know number one enemy it faces
well first of all let me start with your
last point
chinese have crossed a mutually agreed
line of actual control
we drew a line in 1993 saying that there
are disputes
on whose land is whose land
and we will you know take the present
situation the status quo
and will draw a line where there's no
disputes
and in that the chinese got a big chunk
of
kashmir the part of kashmir which is now
called a separate
state called ladakh but over the period
of the previous government they had been
silently coming into
our land and this continued
even after we came to power now i i do
not know whether the prime minister knew
about it i
i can't believe that you wouldn't have
known he had 18
meetings one to one xi jinping
one to one one either in india or in
china or turn by turn and
suddenly out of the blue we come to
learn that they have come and occupied
our land and uh it's about two thousand
square kilometers
and now they are you know they enforce
that they are
increasing their forces i think they are
they are they are thinking
i don't know whether they got a date but
they are certainly going to have another
attack
and the attack was actually by the
chinese aimed at
eliminating india from the global map
that we are number two i mean we are in
the second category of
nations not in the first category of
rest categories only united states and
and china and india is
waffling because we are not able to
we have been uh you know brainwashed
earlier that we should be non-aligned
and not aligned with bot uh with whom
and we should have a clear policy that
today the weapon systems are the
best in the united states we don't want
u.s troops in india
because our troops are sufficient to
deal with china
but we certainly need the weapons
systems
the u.s is willing to give certainly i
would like to see
um i'd like to see your f-35
being given to us you gave it to turkey
i think
but i don't know what is the
the magnet the indians have
decided to sign a contract and pay a
hundred thousand
uh crores uh to
the russians for s 400. now as for
hundreds electronics are entirely
chinese
second i don't know what the world
realizes the russians
in effect are a junior partner of china
they can't go against china they are
bankrupt and the chinese have been
financing them and so therefore
they today we need clarity we can defeat
the chinese we have the weapons we have
the
the the wherewithal to
engage in our warfare because the
logistics is in favor of india the
chinese have to come from a long
distance
and through tibet and then cross a
mountain
then come down so we can defeat them and
in fact
in the hand-to-hand combat we have
already defeated them
but the fact is now it's going to be the
weapon system
and we need to therefore have
a clear understanding of the united
states the main problem with the indian
politicians is we are too emotional if
you praise them
they think oh we are now arrived they
are the greatest in the world
well the americans are all practical
people i've lived with them i know
everything is give and take what's in it
for me
or what i'll give you and what i want
from you now that kind of language you
should speak to the americans
and americans i know want to give up
they want to give up some of their uh
they want to give up some of their
responsibilities in say the indo-pacific
i think we are in a position to take it
tomorrow if india and indonesia came
together the chinese won't be able to go
through the malacca strait
they can't come from their eastern coast
and go to
the to the west because we can stop them
there
so we have that kind of thing but the
chinese are
very hard-working people they have got
the sri lankans on their side
they have got the bangladeshis on their
side all our
neighboring countries are today if
they're not pro-chinese they certainly
don't
annoy them and we're in a terrible
situation
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye